the scariest risk I think that we are
running is if we are wrong about how
much time we have to deal with co2 or if
we had a precipitant event that kind of
dire warner's of climate you know always
say well we'll have the tipping point
well you know we could have the tipping
point and if we had something like a big
hunk of the Greenland ice shall fall off
for example or accelerated release of
methane from the tundra and the Arctic
because of course that's straight co2
emissions and methane remember is much
more dangerous than co2 in terms of its
contribution to climate change so if we
if we're wrong and the earth really were
to accelerate faster than the IPCC says
you know what what if we can't find not
only that we can't live at 450 parts per
million btus what if we find we can't
live at 350 or 300 that would be my
scariest scenario because then I think
on the other hand that might be what we
need to galvanize the world that
business as usual cannot continue and
maybe everybody would come together my
other my other great fear would be that
we is far less catastrophic in the long
run for the future of the globe but my
other concern would be if we had a
catastrophic war in the Middle East and
there was a major disruption to to
petroleum supplies because that would
send the price of oil up probably if it
were to happen you know while we're
still in a global recession probably
send us into depression we win then have
the resources we need to make the
conversion to the renewable energy
future and that would that would also
have very severe implications
the only way I ranked out a high risk is
if we were to have an Israeli attack on
Iran or an Iranian attack on Israel
seems less likely but I think in that
case everybody would immediately become
polarized the United States would be in
a very difficult position with our
historic Israeli ally on the one hand
but probably the entire Arab world
united against us if not formally at
least de facto for their own political
survival and that that would be a very
very serious situation and one that I am
increasingly worried about might occur
because I think largely because of the
intransigence of the Iranians on their
nuclear program I do not believe they're
negotiating in good faith and I do
believe whether you agree with it or not
I do believe that Israel sees Iranian
nuclear armed Iran has an existential
threat and given the current complexion
of the Israeli government on the more
hardline right wing side of the spectrum
I would not rule it out